Look, here-- We're gonna--
We're having such a good time...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-...but...
now you're going
to have to answer
for Sonny on the causeway. Okay.
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
-So, um...
I'm just saying
because to stand up--
you're one of 11 senators,
who voted not to certify
the last election, okay.
One of 11.
Do you think Biden didn't win?
Biden is clearly the president.
Well, that's not the question
or the answer.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
Do you think he won?
Was it a fair election?
Now, but those are
very different questions.
-BILL MAHER: Okay--
-(STAMMERS)
Did he win
and is he the president?
Yes. Was it fair?
Look, there were lots of things
that were unfair
-about the last election.
-But it's been combed over more
than any election ever,
even by the people on your side,
and they say it's not.
This is from your book.
You say,
"Democrats whose capacity
for shamelessness never ceases
to astound me,
were no longer willing to play
by the rules of democracy."
Now, I know you're funny now,
but is that a joke?
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
The Democrats don't want
to play
-by the rules of democracy?
-What was the context
before and after that?
I'm sorry,
the one sentence
I'm not remembering.
Well, that I know--
I don't know,
but you wrote that.
"The Democrats
are no longer willing
to play
by the rules of Democracy."
I wanted to read it
because I feel like,
it's the exact opposite
of what I think,
which is that the Republicans,
including you,
January 6th etcetera,
are the ones who are no longer
willing to play
by the rules of Democracy.
-It seems like--
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
Wait, wait--
It seems like your idea
has switched
in the Republican party to,
"elections only count
if we win,"
and then we will endlessly
litigate them,
even though your own--
It was laughed at a court,
like 60 different courts.
I mean, all we have--
the-- the secretaries of state,
even the Republican ones,
everybody said you're--
Trump's own election,
people said it was the--
one of the most fair,
well-run elections ever.
Why won't you let it go?
So, Bill, you're the one
that's not letting it go,
you're the one
that's asking about it.
But-- but let me be clear
about something.
I'm asking about your history
with it.
Listen I believe passionately
in Democracy,
and-- and I also believe
voter fraud is a real,
and persistent problem,
and it's weird
that Democrats have taken
the view--
BILL: It's not.
It's been studied.
Okay, so you don't think it is,
but you know what,
I have never once seen you
or any other host
ask Hillary Clinton
why she said in 2016
that Donald Trump
was an illegitimate president.
I've never seen
you ask Democrats
why they objected
to the presidential
certification in 2001,
that was George W. Bush
in 2005,
that was George W. Bush,
and in 2016,
that was Donald Trump.
And, so, I don't think we should
be--
have a double standard here.
Okay, well,
there is a double standard,
'cause there's two different
things going on.
One is a remonstration,
a mild protestation
of something-- They did--
Al Gore was the head
of the Senate at the time,
he had to pass the baton
in an election
he knew he won,
-and his--
-TED: He knew he won.
-the other candidates--
-Are you an election denier?
You just said
Al Gore won that election.
Well, he-- Okay, he did not win.
He won the-- I'm sorry,
you're right, you're right.
I meant to say he won
the popular vote. Well--
But-- but-- that's not
what chooses the president.
Yes, I understand.
I understand.
But the other candidate's
brother stopped the count.
Okay, that's--
that is-- that's not accurate.
The Supreme Court stopped
the count, his own brother
-ran that election in Florida--
-His brother was the governor
of Florida,
you know they counted--
Hold on, hold on a second.
I mean, facts matter.
They counted the votes
four times in Florida.
George W. Bush won
all four times,
I was part of the legal team
litigating that case,
so I-- I was intimately
involved in Bush versus Gore.
Every time they counted
the votes, Bush won.
The bigger point
is that Al Gore
took one for the team.
He came out and said,
"Okay, you know,
this was a really
fucked up election,
but this is America."
The jewel in our crown
is that we pass power peacefully
and I'm not gonna be
the first guy
not to do that.
Nixon let it go in 1960,
that could have
been a-- screwy election,
and Hillary came out
in her goddamn purple suit...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-...so she did it
before the sun rose.
She did it before
the cock crowed three times.
She came out and said
"Trump is the president,"
that's what you guys
will not do.
Joe Biden is the president,
what do you mean
we won't do it?
I'm fighting him every day,
and he's screwing up the country
-and the world.
-(BILL LAUGHS)
So, I'm quite aware
Joe Biden's the president,
I wish he wasn't,
but it's not lost on me
who it is that caused a war
in Europe with Ukraine,
that-- that gave
a hundred billion dollars
to Iran and the terrorists
attacking--
-He caused a war in Ukraine?
-Yes, you want to know how?
No, but next time.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-Thank you, Ted Cruz.
All right, thank you,
that was spirited.
-Come back and see us?
-I look forward to it.
All right, I'll see you
on Overtime,
we can finish it up. Ted Cruz.